something that you've been vocal about
is your uh your pub deal yeah and um it
is a mistake that a lot of artists make
uh
not even producers just writers um
signing a pub deal too early and getting
taken advantage of one million percent i
mean i would say you know i've spoke on
this in a bunch of interviews and i
don't want to get too deep right now but
i would just say that any deal period
make sure it's an exit plan make sure
that they can't you know it's like my
pop's been in prison in the system since
he was like 19 years old he's like 50
something now so it's like they're
railroad you and they'll find loopholes
and ways to just keep you down keep you
in and i feel like i'm literally going
through that like no matter how much
money i earn or how much success i have
they don't really have to honor it
because of the way the the contract was
written yeah so it's like make sure you
got an exit plan that's that's the most
have you tried buying yourself out of
the deal oh they won't even let it
happen it's that deep it's like it's
sticky that's cool crazy just keep
airing them out bro because that's
that's why i got to go crazy that's
[ __ ] wild because you say you've been
in it since you were 19. yeah bro just
turned 35.
i've been in 19 16 years that's so crazy
i don't know if like it's uh
acceptable anymore to offer those kind
of deals anymore because i know that
they have not well from what i hear like
they've gotten rid of the uh and was it
the mbrcs
because that's that minimum delivery the
delivery requirement i think where
they'll tell you
um
ten
yeah but that's that's that's a thousand
points yeah so if you do a beat what
would you say hit like if you do a beat
it's like a typical
amount of points you would get on a
record like not even you specifically
just in general your experience in the
music industry if you make the beat i
mean if you got you know a good team and
you got that leverage i would say four
maybe five points sometimes per record
per song
yeah and so yeah so if you have a
thousand points you have to recoup do
the math that's insane that's a lot so
how about this if somebody because you
know a lot of times uh somebody like
yourself a established producer
will reach out and maybe get a loop pack
from somebody i'm not saying you do that
but i mean in general like you know
sometimes
a nice way to get on if you're up and
coming artists is to send loops out yeah
like if you're up-and-coming producer
if uh
someone uses your loop
was that something that what what what
is ideally what did you even get cut in
on the pub at that point
i mean yeah i mean it just depends on
what y'all work out right or if they
have a set thing like oh this is this is
this is these are my terms or whatever
but most of times it's like you know it
depends on how much they do like i'm a
super fair guy a lot of people like even
my counselor i've been like yo you was
you was like you're a super fair person
like it's people that take people's
whole beats and don't even give them and
just throw the tag on it you know what
i'm saying like this i see that [ __ ] a
lot yeah yeah